[Music]
good stuff
1602 we go e4
knight c6 so this is the nimzovich
defense there are two basic choices here
you can go d4
but the simplest move is actually to go
knight f3 because usually this
transposes there we go this transposes
after e5 into whatever
uh whatever you play here now the
downside of this is that you
avoid the vienna if you're a vienna
player you would want to go knight c3
here but i would like to play the four
night scotch
as we've been doing
thus far
and let's see how this works at at a
1600 level now i would say that people
still struggle against this opening
at this level and there we go this is
already an inaccuracy and
we might see c5 bishop e7
black is already in huge trouble what
should i do here and this can be
punished very very
[Music]
um straightforwardly and in
you know with with tremendous strength
yeah black has failed to play d6 so of
course we play e5 we push the knight
back all the way to g8
okay knight h5 is a very typical mistake
any time there's a knight on h5 or a5
you have to make a mental association
with a particular move
and this move needs to be like an
automatic reaction to knight h5 or
knight a5 this is sometimes even missed
by grand masters so not bishop e2
because when you attack a piece with
another piece right the the left the
lower value
uh a piece is the better of an attacker
it is as i've discussed pawns and this
might sound paradoxical but it's
actually very straightforward pawns are
the best attackers because if a pawn
attacks a piece you can't really defend
that piece with another pawn and
therefore the move is g4 black can't
really play g6 here that's the logic
g4 traps the knight
okay this is game over
and in the in addition black is and here
comes c5 so it's a double whammy
um
black has also opened the g file for us
thank you very much and now we need to
sort of reorient ourselves toward
attacking the king so
normally we would slide the queen back
or maybe bring it to a4
but here specifically i i see a really
nice square for the queen now a lot of
you are tempted by queen g4 but uh don't
forget to check for uh your opponent's
ideas right the bishop on c8 it's going
to be x-raying the queen queen g4 allows
the move d5 and black gets his pieces
out
um
rapidly
so where am i thinking about putting the
queen here
call me rey sees it i am
i have my eye on queen e4 why queen e4
because well who can explain this to me
why queen e4
yeah so we want to play bishop d3 but f6
is actually kind of an interesting move
because bishop d3 can now be met with
the move f5
so i'd like to play a slightly more
flexible move until black puts their
cards on the table
so what attacking move can we make that
we know for a fact
uh increases the strength of anything
that we do
on the on the on the king side of course
the move is rookie one now am i not
worried about my king not being able to
castle we weren't planning to castle
that way anyway if we want to castle
we'll castle queenside
now that f takes e5 has been played how
does this impact the position well if
you think about it that means black
can't play f5
why is it important that black can't
play f5
well you tell me now we play bishop d3
and the game is over immediately
very straightforward logic and that said
h7 is unstoppable and boom boom boom
yeah
we'll probably play another one
because there's really nothing to
analyze here at all
okay h6
oh we have a really pretty mate if you
guys want um
look find find the pretty me now there's
made in three two different ways that i
see
yeah rook g7 that's the elegant way to
do it king g7
and then either queen h7 and queen g64
queen g6 queen h7 this is an interesting
case of symmetry right you can rarely is
this the case you can go this way that
way or that way this way
um
yeah that's about it now you could also
play queen h7 queen g6 and queen g7
easy game not much to talk about here
again you guys can see fortnite scotch
is a powerhouse at this level i mean
nobody knows what to do against it yet
and people just tend to take on d4 right
right this is this is already a mistake
and as we've discussed
black has to play d6 here that's very
important otherwise we go e5 and
here knight g8 is the only move
but um
you know then we go bishop c4 and this
is incredibly nasty because the knight
isn't even coming out to h6 because we
can take it
um
and
even gm's occasionally missed this like
g4 idea this can be an easy move to
forget about
that's it castles we take the knight the
only subtlety is where to put the queen
here right this is something that you
acquire through experience right how do
i know i want to put any for well i'm
just very familiar with the idea of
building a battery
and also i'm
incorporating the fact this pawn on e5
essentially precludes f5 because we can
always take on passant understood
all right let's play another one that
was
that was easy
16 13 from azerbaijan as zekka
okay e4
well um let's
i i feel like playing another
accelerated dragon oh no never mind
white plays four this is really good uh
this is a move which if you're a
sicilian player you should definitely
know how to respond to it i i don't know
if it has a formal name i think i
informally refer to it as the
accelerated grand prix because in the
general grand prix white plays knight c3
and the way that you quote unquote
punish this and i want to emphasize that
this move is not a reputation of f4 but
this is what what is recommended in most
uh opening books and i believe it's the
best movement that is d5
now i've i've had this before in a speed
run he takes d5 you don't take with the
queen you play knight f6 this is quite
common in such positions e5 essentially
allows you to get a good french type of
structure so what should we do here
what is the the almost automatic
response
in such situations not e6 no no no e6
literally transposes to a french
first we get the bishop outside the
punching you guys know that first we get
the bishop outside the pawn chain
right then we play e6 otherwise
everybody would do this this would
transpose into a french
okay and we don't have to rush with
these six we don't have to rush rush
with e6 we can start with knight cc it's
not like white's not gonna play e6
let's get our knight out first
this should be fine
now
are we worried about the prospect of
bishop take c6 check well i wouldn't
necessarily say the answer is no
uh and as i'll show you guys after the
game this pawn structure specifically is
often quite problematic for black and
this is something that is very unique to
these positions so i'll flesh that out
after the game through the lens of
perhaps an over the board game
what is an elegant and active way to
take the sting out of bishop take c6
well what does it mean to take this
thing out of this move it means to
prepare to capture with a piece
queen b6 definitely
yeah no d5 there okay so now we take
with the queen and everything is groovy
we have preserved our pawn structure
and now it's time for us to develop our
king side
d3 okay let's uh let's go e6
now
the one issue in such situations is that
if you would want to go knight f6 but
you can't so if you're a caracon player
then you generally know how to approach
the question of where to develop these
where does the night of bishop belong
because there's
not a lot of real estate on the king
side
that um
you know there's just not a lot of room
there
so there's a couple of ways that you can
address this and the sort of textbook
method is to start by going 97 knight g6
and then going bishop b7 but there are
also a couple of other methods
um some of them a little bit more
creative
i don't like g6 because fianchettoing
the bishop is just biting on granite on
e5 the more creative method is to get
the knight out to h6 and the bishop on
e7
uh the drawback of that is that white
can go h3 and kind of put the knight out
of commission but i'm going to show you
guys a really cool idea an idea that i
think is really cool and we'll start
with the move bishop b7 so we'll start
with the most flexible developing move
and uh as we discussed so
knight h6 allows h3 right and the knight
is out of commission but if you watch
for example hikaru play uh the
gurganidze
you might know that black is a very
particular kind of move that is often
played in such structures
uh it grabs space and it also prepares
something important what am i talking
about and that is the move h5
so this does a couple of things it
prepares the move knight h6
which uh
we are now going to play
and let me now explain why now if the
pawn was not on h5 here if the pawn was
on h7 a little thought experiment what
move would be possible now for white
nasty little move if the pawn was on h7
right now instead of on h5 what could
white do
why would be able to go g4
with the pawn being on h5 it's prevented
it's preventing g4 and it is allowing a
further regrouping of pieces think about
the snide on h6 where do you really want
it what little re
reshuffling can you propose here again
if you
watch
if you're familiar with these structures
you should know about this
bishop yeah bishop g6 and knight f5
exactly i guess why i can play g
white can play g4 here but that allows
us to open the h file and i feel like
the white king is going to be so exposed
there that we don't have to worry about
this move
does that make sense why does the knight
belong in f5 well it's just really good
there
and
we can also push this pawn down to h4
perhaps we should have done that earlier
we could have done that earlier and that
completely prevents g4 because of the
possibility of on passant okay that is a
blunder
why
knight d2 is just a blunder yeah thing
thank you for the center pawn we will
take it gladly
and we can drop back and proceed with
our plan
gladly take that pawn
if you want to be really accurate
you might say well we don't even really
have to bring the bishop back to g6 this
bishop on e3 is perfectly safe it can be
supported by the move c4 or they can
move back toward this diagonal
um but we don't need to i actually don't
like but actually no let me think about
this for a second
i don't love the immediate c4 although
boom boom boom
we'll play it
yeah let's play it but it i okay
this is very concrete i don't like it
positionally but i think it works out
tactically can somebody explain to me
why i might be reluctant about playing
this move from a positional standpoint
what is the drawback and yes it
threatens bishop c5 i see that but what
is the drawback of this move from a
positional standpoint
it weakens the d4 square it creates a
big hole on d4
now if you can defend that hole with
your pieces and you can make sure of
that then this is fine and it took me a
while to figure out that we can there we
go our opponent tries to exploit it
what should we do
i know a lot of you are attempted by
bishop c5 it's the right idea but you
don't want to give the bishop up for the
knight this dark squared bishop is very
valuable look at how many weak dark
squares white actually has
instead we bring the knight to f5 just
in time we bring the knight to f5 just
in time
the move that i was trying to calculate
for the record is g4 in this position
i think we're doing well after g4 but i
had to work that out
and so
in a over the board game i wouldn't go
c4 i would i would wait for a more
opportune moment to play that
this is a very instructive moment
because i can get i'm sure that most of
you are probably thinking okay now we
should take but i actually think we can
squeeze more out of this position
um without taking nd4 why do i how do i
know that why do i say that because if
you take on d4 then the diagonal is
plugged by the pawn
whereas if we can get this knight off of
d4 the threat of bishop c5 is going to
become incredibly strong
now bishop c5 immediately blunders the
queen
so do we want to play queen c5 no well
we want the bishop on c5 so we want the
queen on b6
why does it check on a4 it's not scary
just go king f8
does this make sense this logic makes
sense
now we're threatening knight takes d4
and queen takes before knight f3 okay
intensify
intensify now the move is bishop c5 now
we're threatening to win a second pawn
on d4 and we've got white basically tied
up in knots
bishop e3 we take it we take those
bishops
and this is what happens right when you
put a sufficient amount of pressure on
players in this rating range generally
you'll see you know these these kinds of
blunders
um
and that's not entirely uncommon and
it's totally normal
okay
so
yeah so f4 the move is d5 and there is
quite a bit of theory here if you
actually look at books and stuff he
takes d5
uh you go knight f6 you try to take this
pawn on your own terms
and if white goes c4 then i've i
definitely have a speedrun game with
this opening i think our opponent went
c4 so you can
dig around
on search by opening but after e6 the
basic idea is that black has tremendous
compensation for
the pawn and as i explained in that
earlier video
uh black's compensation hinges on three
primary things
um let's see if you guys can name all
three reasons that i have in mind and
there are different ways of looking at
this position so it's not like there's a
clear like okay this is how it is this
is how i think about the position
development is not really one of them so
that's an interesting way that my
intuition differs from yours
because white is going to get his king
side developed right
why can go knight f3 bishop to castles
so the development advantage is going to
be
diluted in the next couple of moves
so
first thing is the backward d pawn and
that more importantly this d4 square is
a giant weakness
right as long as we have control over d4
we're making it very hard for white to
develop
um the second thing is the open king yes
and why is it open because there's a
pawn enough for and it's sticking out
like a sore thumb so even if white
castles king side white's king is not
going to be entirely out of the woods
and the fact that the pawn is on f4 it
doesn't just weaken the king i think a
lot of people don't fully understand
that it creates spillover effects
on other pieces for example
if you think about a move like bishop b3
now it's always going to run into knight
g4 because there's no pawn on f2 to
anchor that bishop so it weakens the
whole center makes it hard for white to
put pieces in the center and it makes it
hard for white to get this bishop
somewhere active so that's reason number
two
and then reason number three
is is just that white's light squared
bishop is terrible it it's perpetually
and both of white's bishops are terrible
you could you could put it that way both
of them are staring at pawns on the
fourth rank
so
this is a good way you know this i think
this is a good kind of thing to do is
just to look at a position see if you
can really deconstruct it and break it
down into its component elements like
black gets compensation for the pawn or
you flip on the engine you see that
okay it shows a slight advantage for
black and you really try to figure out
why that is conceptually
good
um
but i won't delve further into the
theory of this line white doesn't have
to go c4 white also has bishop b5 check
here and knight c3 and you can do your
own
research but after e5 bishop f5 this is
already really really good
and and this is essentially a french
with a pawn on f4 which is very much
subpar and a bishop outside the pawn
chain both of which are in black's favor
obviously
all right so let me see if i can find a
a cautionary tale of what happens
when you leave
when you allow
when you allow
white to take on c6 and ruin your pawn
structure okay let me see if i can find
an example of this
okay so two two pretty good players you
can see
white's a gm
um and
basically they get the structure
they get the structure
right and and what happens here
is that first of all white goes e5 in
this position which causes tremendous
problems in black structure right it
breaks up the whole pawn structure if
you take it
this is incredibly ugly so
white just clamps down in the position
but after black goes d5 we get the exact
structure that we could have got in the
game and here's what white does
knight a4 typical move in such positions
f6 bishop b3 what is white doing thank
you favela white is putting pressure on
the c5 pawn why is that important
because it makes it incredibly look how
stock black is black can't go knight b6
black can't get the light-skirt bishop
out i can't move the dark squared bishop
it's just
incredibly hard to move around here
because of these
you know this host of weaknesses on
the
you know in in the
um
on the queen side
and what black tries to take on e5 but
then after the mass trade queen f2
queen f3 is a nice move eventually white
takes on c5 and look at this monster
knight sitting on that outpost and
although black's pawn structure visually
looks better white's got this absolute
monster knight there's a pawn on a6
that's weak
sorry white doesn't take it and white
ends up black ends up giving up the
exchange but
losing the game rather quickly
afterwards
hopefully that makes this is not not an
ideal illustration but i think it shows
you the sort of the spirit of what i'm
trying to say
um and so for that reason we decided to
go queen b6 why allow this
so like if you think about it white can
apply many of the same ideas that we
just saw bishop b3 knight bd2 knight b3
and start pressuring the spawn on c5 and
if you ever go d4 in a position like
this you create big light square
weaknesses
so
queen b6
now does that mean you always have to be
afraid of this no the structure isn't
necessarily bad but here there was just
no need
so yeah here we go bishop e7
um and we adopt this h5 idea knight h6
bishop g6 knight f5 you see this often
in the caricon
if if you're a caracon player
um
if you're a caracon player you should
definitely be
aware of this idea again i can show you
a gazillion examples
of this particular
transformation of this particular setup
in fact i think i actually played a game
myself
where i
faced this yeah so this is where i first
learned about this this game
so this is a game that i played in 2011.
against a peruvian peruvian grandmaster
and as you can see it was a karo khan it
was in advance
and guess what he did knight h6 i was
unfamiliar with this move back then he
didn't play h5
um so he played it without h5 but bishop
g6
and then
knight f5 so
you can see it here and
who can explain to me why g4 is not
scary in this position like why is h5
unnecessary well first of all black
castle's king side so he didn't want to
ruin the king side but
more importantly there is simply knight
h4 and
white has created a lot of holes on the
king side i later did play jeep in fact
i did play g4 on the very next move but
after knight h4 i ended up getting in a
lot of trouble on the king side because
the thing is
like f4 f6 and now the king side is
opened
and he sticks a bishop on e4 eventually
so he put me under a lot of pressure
although i managed to save the draw
good stuff there and back to the game
yeah so h3 here we go h5 because we
don't have to castle king's side yet we
can just keep our king in the center
bishop back he blunders the pawn which
helps our cause i think i myself would
have probably gone knight f5
um but yeah we decided on this approach
and uh
queen b6 is an important move so again
if we take it and go queen b6
then white goes bishop b3 and your
bishop on e7 doesn't really have a home
he could have taken quinn h5 where
oh here but then we have bishop c5 no
that was the point of c4 i thought
so not we can't really do it concretely
queen b6 knight f3 bishop c5
and uh after bishop d3
no but then we take the rook
the rook is hanging
the rook is saying
um
yeah so so the key thing to establish
here is whether we can keep these
squares under control and when i realize
that i can this is this is a move that
took me a second to find i also
had to ensure that queen a4 isn't
dangerous because of king fa because
otherwise you actually drop a rook
so
this is important okay obviously bishop
b3
eases our our cause but
that's that's that um
a lot of a lot of uh positional concepts
to flesh out in this game even though it
was short
but yeah c5 f4 you want to go d5
straight away
and knight c3 which is the actual grand
prix
you can either go knight c6 or d6 or e6
depending on
so here depending on which which
sicilian you play against the open
sicilian you want to calibrate your
response to knight c3 because a lot of
tricky people they'll go knight c3 and
if you're a night off player for example
knight c6 they'll suddenly go knight f3
like wait a minute i didn't sign up for
this
right you go d6 you get move ordered
into a rouser so if you're a knight or
flare traditionally you're supposed to
go d6 or a6 here
so that if white goes knight f3 you can
go knight f6 and preserve
uh the the the night or setup or if
you're a dragon player same thing if
you're a dragon player you can actually
go g6 immediately uh why not h4 to
strengthen the knife because we weren't
afraid of g4 that was the point yeah
getting movement is annoying and so
that's one of the
ways you can fine-tune your repertoire
to make sure that you're not susceptible
to getting reordered so that's what i'll
say okay guys i am going to call it a
night i'm tired thank you guys thanks
for now have a good one see you tomorrow
[Music]